so Bitcoin last week or two weeks ago at
this point had a massive drawdown drew
down 50% it's down about 30% give or
take right now from from kind of free
the coronavirus financial crunch if you
are the liquidity crisis a lot of people
are looking around the room and saying
hey is it over right and one of the
metrics or models that people use is the
stock to flow model to understand kind
of where bitcoin is and is it doing what
it's supposed to do or staying on track
I know you've got a lot of thoughts
about the stock to flow model and kind
of how the the recent price drop plays
into that maybe talk a little bit about
how you see those two events kind of
overlapping so I guess the numbers I
always like to look at is the start of
the year so although you're right from
saying that before the coronavirus kind
of hit you know I looked I I personally
was looking at the coronavirus back in
January and I was like this is gonna be
really bad super bad because of the
videos and the numbers we were seeing
out of China but if we were just gonna
look at the numbers from the start of
the year because it just gives you a
little bit more context on performance
the start of the year Gold is down 1.6%
Bitcoin from the start January first is
down 4.6 5% and the S&P 500 is down
negative 31 percent and people just
gotta understand these numbers you know
that it's just it's it's kind of crazy
to me how long people can keep their
head in the sand as to the performance
of this thing it's just somewhat
mind-blowing to me so go into what you
were saying there about stock the flow
so plan B comes out with this this
article brilliant article and he's
comparing the the stock the existing
amount of everything anyone who's
listening to this as the Bitcoin or
obviously knows what how this thing is
measured it's your stock the amount of
bitcoins that are currently on the
market versus the flow how many are
being dropped at whatever rate and when
you're looking at this thing and you're
seeing how accurate the r-squared value
is on this it's
I've never seen anything like this in
trading the markets since I've been
doing it for two decades not anything
close to this and when people saw the
price and as we're approaching the next
four year having typically what you've
seen in the past is that the price
really starts to narrow its volatility
around that intrinsic value I call it an
intrinsic value or that stock the flow
about as soon as the four-year cycle or
I'm sorry as soon as the four-year
having occurs you see that volatility
separate away from that intrinsic value
or that stock the flow value
tremendously but as it but as time
marches on you see that volatility kind
of start coming in and kind of become
fixated into that real tight price
pattern and you're seeing the same thing
play out right now but I think what
surprised everybody with this recent
drop is is they were not expecting this
I was not expecting this drop at all but
I wasn't expecting the supply and demand
shock that we saw that came out of the
coronavirus at the level that we saw it
I was expecting uh supplying to man
shock but not anywhere near I mean car
sales down like 80 percent I mean these
numbers are not even fathomable for
anybody that follows financial markets
like these numbers are insane absolutely
insane so what you gotta understand is
the derivatives market is just one giant
I would call it half casino and half
risk mitigation what I mean by that is
you have you get let's just say you have
an airline company like they're trying
to protect their risk in the oil market
right so they're there for the right
reasons to mitigate their risk they just
look at it as an insurance cost but then
the people on the other side of that
trade are pretty much high-stakes
gamblers and people that are you know
speculators right and so when those
assumptions that are being made as to
what supply and demand is going to look
like in the future drastically change
yes what
you have massive impairment on one of
those two peoples balance sheets massive
impairments and so how do you how do you
fix your impairment well you got to go
to Fiat you got a swap straight into
dollars into euros whatever the
denomination is for that derivative
you've got a swap into that Fiat and I'm
not talking about credit I'm talking
about monetary baseline Fiat that you've
got to swap into in order to adjudicate
that impairment on those balance sheets
and so think about what we just saw we
saw the biggest supply and demand shock
I think you could you could argue the
world has ever seen right we just saw
the biggest supply demand shock which
means you had the biggest amount of
impairment that we've ever seen in the
derivatives market ever right and so if
people don't understand how big the
derivatives market is wrap your head
around this figure this the derivatives
market when you look at shadow
derivatives you look at reported
derivatives then you look at unfunded
government liabilities all inside of
this derivative market you're talking
1600 trillion right so that is such a
big number that people hear it and
they're just like all that yeah that's a
big number but to just kind of wait to
lay a little context to it right let's
just assume the gold markets 10 trillion
just for easy math and that you know
you'll hear people say it's six or seven
or eight really no matter but let's just
make the number around here let's say
it's a 10 trillion dollar market for the
entire global gold market okay this is a
hundred and sixty times bigger than that
that's how big this is capitalized as
far as the derivatives so when you're
talking about a 1600 trillion dollar
derivative market that has massive
impairment that everyone's got a swap
into fiat fixed monetary baseline fiat
in order to adjudicate all those
derivative positions
you better darn well believe everything
and I mean everything is gonna be sold
in order to come up with the dollars
that are inside of all that
capitalization to adjudicate this stuff
right so just to say that Bitcoin went
down and has already had quite a decent
recovery I mean hold on let me look at
the flippin chart hold on let me do the
math real fast Bitcoin has already
recovered 50% since the bottom of this
derivative event right and now it might
not stay there it might go back down
that could happen I know but the fact
that it has rebounded 50% off of that to
me is mind-numbing how resilient in
honeybadger like this flippin thing is
yeah it is absolutely incredible and I
said to somebody you've got to remember
that take equity markets for example
they've got the circuit breakers they've
got hours of operation they've got all
kinds of mechanisms in place to tamp
down volatility and do everything they
can to not have a free market because
frankly they're scared of what would
happen when you do have a truly free
market in times of panic uncertainty
fear etc bitcoin is a free market right
there's no circuit breakers there's no
hours of operations and so when you get
that moment where everyone is selling
everything the fact that it only drew
down 50% is wild and then if you look at
things like I think Nick Carter and the
folks at coin metrics did a study that
almost all of the Bitcoin that was sold
in that sell-off was Bitcoin that had
moved in the last six months or sooner
so it was no long-term holders it was no
anybody with strong hands it was all the
traders the Wall Street firms the the
people who had just bought it and didn't
know what they were doing or kind of
knew into this and so I think it just
continues to prove out this thesis that
there's two types of people who hold
Bitcoin there's the financial
speculators and then there's the
long-term holders I don't think there's
a single thing that could happen to
shake the holders out of out of Bitcoin
obviously the financial speculators
something as simple as a liquidity
crisis you know they take good
get out of it soon enough and you get a
50% drop in a free market so I agree
with everything you just said and and if
you notice that was I had quite the
smirk on my face because the speculators
that got shook out of their positions
and this might be a really gross
opinion for for some people I don't know
but for me when they sweat down I was
just I was just like this ain't nothing
but a thing this is just the derivatives
market blowing up and they have to sell
their positions these are all
speculators they're the people that I
don't want to own this stuff because
they're the people that I don't want to
have influence in the rebuilding of this
after all this shakes out so the fact
that that that sell-off pushed those
coins into the hands of the
knowledgeable and the people that
actually understand and they've done all
the hard work to understand what in the
world's going on those are the people
that we want to influence and shape the
future let me tell you they are so I was
I just looked at it as a blessing it is
like oh hell yeah this is great